après les excès l'abstinence le moi sans
alcool plus connu sous le nom de dry
januar il y a débuté depuis maintenant
une semaine pour les fêtards plus
question de terminer les bouteilles ou
même de les commencer un défi donc et la
possibilité d'améliorer sa santé ouais
il se reportage à Tours de Faustine
ne pas boire d'alcool pendant 31 jours
d'affilée c'est le défi que s'est lancé
Florian avec l'un de ses amis lui qui
aime faire la fête à l'habitude de boire
quelques verres lors de ses sorties deux
à trois fois par semaine alors même si
son entourage n'y croit pas trop il va
tenter le dry January pour la première
fois je pense pas que ce soit dur après
c'est sûr au niveau des soirées
j'apprends un peu le fait de de sortir
les sur Tours ou sur plume précisément
mais on va prendre des bières sans
alcool ou impériés tranches et on verra
ce que ça donne mais je pense que on
peut quand même se passer de pendant
minimum 30 jours d'alcool c'est pas un
truc de dingue non plus l'idée étant de
réduire sa consommation d'alcool sur le
long terme après pourquoi pas ne plus
boire en semaine ou avoir un petit excès
en une fois par mois une fois tous les
deux mois Frédéric quand elle participe
au drive January pour la troisième année
même si elle estime sa consommation qu'à
deux verres par semaine c'est une
expérience qu'elle trouve bénéfique ça
m'apporte un mieux-être c'est à dire que
de faire un peu plus attention
pas que j'ai une grande consommation
d'alcool mais je trouve que pour les
fêtes on a souvent tendance à boire plus
que d'habitude donc d'être plus en forme
et puis se lancer un défi parce que on
peut dire oui c'est facile de pas boire
d'alcool mais en fin de compte même si
on n'en boit pas souvent c'est pas
évident de ne pas en boire pendant 31
jours hors des études démontre car était
l'alcool même pendant seulement un mois
peut effectivement avoir des effets
positifs sur la santé le bénéfice le
plus fréquent d'abord c'est d'être
content
après il y a des bénéfices en termes de
qualité de vie on va mieux dormir sentir
moins fatigué
en termes physiques on va avoir
potentiellement une perte de poids après
il y a d'autres paramètres
physiologiques qui vont baisser au bout
d'un mois sans alcool on va voir la
pression artérielle la fréquence
cardiaque qui vont diminuer le taux de
cholestérol aussi qui peuvent baisser
n'oublions pas que santé publique France
recommande de ne pas boire plus de deux
verres par jour et pas tous les jours